- Les ventes de permis de pêche
au Québec ont augmenté au cours
des dernières années, passant
de 709 000 en 2019 à 767 000
en 2021. Ici, plusieurs petits
apprentis pêcheurs se préparent.
- C'est le fun.
- Moi, j'aime aussi beaucoup
manger les poissons, c'est bon.
- Et au-delà de l'activité,
la possibilité de consommer
ses prises.
JACYNTHE LAMARRE,
maman de la tribu
- Je ne savais pas qu'on pouvait
ramener les poissons, donc
heureusement ça fait mon
bonheur. Et j'imagine que ça va
faire leur bonheur aussi.
- On compte environ 118 espèces
de poissons dans les eaux douces
du Québec. Bien que toutes
ces espèces soient comestibles,
une trentaine rerésentent
un intérêt culinaire. Et ici,
dans les eaux du fleuve
Saint-Laurent, on retrouve plus
de 80 espèces de poissons.
YVES OUELLETTE, propriétaire
Centre de pêche du vieux port
- Tout le temps la même
question, est-ce qu'on peut
garder le poisson? Bien oui,
tu peux le garder! Bien oui,
tu peux le manger! C'est...
le poisson est bon, normalement
c'est du doré! On a été dans
la facilité extrêmement
longtemps, hier c'était facile,
l'inflation c'était pas si gros.
Et là, veut, veut pas,
les ménages se disent: écoute
ça commence à couter cher,
les loyers ont doublés, trippés,
l'essence a doublé. Fait que,
le monde vont chercher
des alternatives différentes,
en s'amusant.
- En effet, le prix du panier
d'épicerie a augmenté de 76,9 %
depuis 1995, et c'est la viande
qui a le plus augmenté.
Résultat? L'intérêt pour
les poissons d'ici se fait
de plus en plus sentir sur
la glace, et aussi dans
les épiceries. Chez Métro,
par exemple, la direction
confirme que les ventes
de poissons ont connu une bonne
augmentation au cours des deux
dernières années, spécialement
les produits canadiens.
Même son de cloche chez
les poissonniers. Sean Warren a
ouvert son commerce il y a
deux ans. Il a fait le choix
de privilégier des produits
locaux, par exemple, le doré.
En haute saison, 90% de
ses produits proviennent
du Québec et des maritimes.
SEAN WARREN, propriétaire
Poissonerie
- Oui, il y a une très très
forte demande, les gens
demandent le poisson
du Québec. Il y a des
poissons... qui voulaient,
admettons, du saumon... vient
pas du Québec, ben ils vont se
tourner vers un autre poisson
qui lui est du Québec. C'est du
thon jaune.
- Chez Delmo.
- Chez Delmo, une véritable
institution à Montréal, on offre
des produits de la mer, et
du doré depuis 1934.
BENOIT DESSUREAULT,
Co-propriétaire CHEZ DELMO
- Celui-ci date de 1964.
Filet de doré meunière...à 2,10$
- Les prix ont augmenté avec
les années, mais la demande est
toujours là.
-Le doré évidemment, qui est
le poisson le plus vendu ici.
- Sauf que la vente commerciale
du doré est interdite au Québec,
malgré sa popularité
grandissante.
- On a le droit de le pêcher,
on peut le manger, mais on ne
peut pas le vendre. Ce que
je peux avoir de plus frais,
ça vient de l'Ontario pour
le doré, si je pouvais l'avoir
des Laurentides, c'est sûr que
ça serait encore mieux.
- Du haut de ses 10 ans, Louna
n'a pas l'intention d'aller
à l'épicerie ou au restaurant
pour manger du poisson.
LOUNA, 10 ans
- En été, j'ai déjà pêché?
- Et tu aimes ça pêcher?
- Oui beaucoup !
- Pourquoi ?
- Parce que j'aime le thon,
j'aime tous les poissons, j'aime
vraiment manger les animaux
dans la mer.